A hash function basically as we said,
the input is a password, this box is
the hash function, whatever computation
goes on here is going to happen here.
And the output, this password could be
any length, could be a past phrase that
combines a bunch of words,
letters, digits, whatever it is.
But it produces the hash
value is of a fixed length.
In this direction we said,
it's one way so it's easy to go.
It's easy to compute this
function given this input and
for us to produce this output.
If it just had this and wanted to invert
it going the other direction that's
going to be really hard, which is the
basis of which we're talking about here.
Given that we're going to derive
something from a password using
a hash function and store that,
let's talk about a couple of threats.
because of the security mindset we have,
anytime we sort of make a decision,
we want to think about its
security implications.
So what are some threats?
We are going to assume that the one-way
property of the hash functions holds.
You make some assumptions so
we are going to assume that inwarding or
going the other direction from
hash value to a password,
we're not going to worry about that.
Let's say we're talking
about common passwords.
You know that password is a common
password, or one, two, three,
four, five is a common password,
but this hash function is known.
This one-way hash function we're talking
about, we're not doing security,
web security, so it's known.
We can compute the hash values
off the common passwords.
And we're saying these hash
values are stored by the system,
those are the derived values.
If you can get hold of the hash values
the system has and if you can find
the hash values for the common passwords
among those stored values, it's not hard
to see how we can find out passwords
of certain users in the system.
So if the hash value of 1, 2, 3, 4,
5 matches with the stored value, we know
that user's password is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
The other kind of attacks we can mount,
one is called a dictionary attack.
So it's like a dictionary
has lots of words and
think about a long list of passwords,
a dictionary of possible passwords.
Words and maybe they're mutated in
a certain way, you add a few digits or
something like that, but you have
this called space of passwords or
the dictionary of passwords, and you can
try to brute force each one of them.
That's called a dictionary attack.
An offline attack is one where we're
not interacting with the system.
We're not trying to log in each time,
we try a different password.
If you do that, then you are, that's
called an online attempt we are making.
We are interacting with the system so
when you do an online, sort of guessing
attack, the system can stop you
after a certain number of tries.
It locks you out.
So, to avoid that problem we can
sort of offline in our free time,
we can take the hash values,
take a dictionary and
sort of compute for each dictionary
word the hash value and search for
that in the set of hash
values that we have.
When we find a match
we know our password.
And we can do this as I said
without interacting the system.
We interact with the system only
when we discover a correct password.
So those are called offline attacks and
dictionary attacks,
sort of brute force attacks.
So one thing even when
we store derive values
in particular hash values here these
kind of attacks are always possible.
Common passwords, the hash value,
dictionary or offline attacks.
The assumption here is that the attacker
does have access to the hash values.
And the hash values don't
immediately allow him or
her to find out the password.
They can try different, or try to
guess the passwords that match and
when they run into a match for
the hash value then they know for
sure that this is the password.
So these are the kind of attacks
that are possible even when you
only store hash values.